انضموا الينا الان من القاهره الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه دكتور هشام الحلبي
اهلا بك طبعا هناك تعزيزات عسكريه جديده
ليكياف على الرغم من الخسائر الكبيره التي
منيت بها والانتقادات الكثيره ايضا التي
وجهت الاستراتيجيه
العسكريه سؤال يبقى هل هذه التعزيزات من
بينها دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه التي وصلت
للتو اوكرانيا من الممكن ان تغير من
مجريات الامور على الارض
الامداد بالدبابات سواء برمز او تشالنجر
كان من وقت طويل جدا اعلن عنه وبالتالي في
استعداد عالي جدا من القوات المسلحه
الروسيه
لمواجهه هذه الدبابات وتدميرها خاصه ان
الدبابات ابرامز الامريكيه فيها ذخائر
جهاز المنظم وهذا
الشكل من الذخائر حقيقه هيخفض مع نوات
الجنود الروس فلا بديل امام روسيا الا
تدمير هذه الدبابات بسرعه وبشكل متكامل
النقطه المهمه ان عدد النبات قليل 31
دبابه جابها الروسيه الاوكرانيه في
مسافتها حوالي 1000 كيلو وبالتالي مجمل
هذه الاسباب انها لن تحدث فرقا في خط
الجبهه ولن تضيف الى اوكرانيا الكثير لان
هي في استعداد عالي جدا من روسيا لتدمير
هذه الدبابات عندما يقول اذا الكرمله انه
بامك انه ان يدمر هذه الدبابات على الارض
وبشكل سريع يبدو هذا السيناريو واقعيا وما
يلزم بالتالي الجيش الاوكراني لتغيير
مجريات المعركه
سيناري واقعي لانهم
استعدوا لهذا السيناريو منذ فتره طويله
كيف ما هي الذخائر التي سيتم استخدامها ضد
الدبابات الوسائل درب بطاقه بدون طيار او
ايضا صواريخ محموله من على الكشف او
بطائرات تقليديه كل هذا الاستعداد
جاهزين له من فتره طويله وبالتالي ده
السبب اللي انا بقول انها سيتم تدميرها
ولن تحدث فرقا كبيرا في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه لصالح اوكرانيا طب هل مشكله في
التعزيزات التي ترسل الى اوكرانيا يعني
هناك جدل دائما بين من يتهم اوكرانيا
بانها ضيعت الكثير من الفرص ولم تحسن
اداره المعارك على الارض من يتهم على
العكس الحلفاء الغربيين بعدم الامداد
بسرعه وبالكميه اللازمه والنوعيه اللازمه
من السلاح
الاراضي الروسيه بالتالي وفق الاسلحه
المقدمه حتى الان ليكياف في حال استمر هذا
السيناريو هل تصبح الحرب محسومه لموسكو
في تقدير ان الحرب البريه اصبحت محسومه
وان خط الجبهه لن يتحرك
كثيرا في اتجاه او لصالح روسيا او لصالح
اوكرانيا
كل ما هنالك ان كل طرف يحاول ان يستهدف
قوات الطرف الاخر بحيث هذه القوات تدفع
ثمن باهظا ويتم تدميرها في اماكنها وده
اللي ممكن يؤدي على المدى الزمني الطويل
الاستنزاف كل طرف للجانب الاخر
ونتمسكه بالارض تصبح كبيره عليه وده ممكن
يجعله ينسحب شكرا لك الخبير العسكريه
واستراتيجي هشام الحلبيه كنت معنا ايضا من
القاهره